>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
[ Pause ]
>> Roberta Shaffer: Good afternoon.
My name is Roberta Shaffer,
and I have the absolute
pleasure every day serving
as the 24th Law Librarian
of Congress.
At one time in my career I also had
under my wing this
phenomenal facility,
the National Audiovisual
Conservation Center,
also known as the Packard Campus,
and so it is indeed a pleasure
to be back here in Culpeper,
Virginia doing a joint program
with the Culpeper Packard Campus
and The Library of Congress,
the Law Library of Congress, and
we are located on Capitol Hill,
the main location of the
Library in Washington,
D.C. So this afternoon we are
celebrating 50 years of Miranda,
and actually the basic principle
of discouraging self-incrimination
is first found in history
in the 13th Century cited
by Moses Maimonides,
who talked about the fact that
you should not force someone
to be a witness against them self.
And we see that in American
law, it traveled through many,
many Supreme Court and lower
Court and State Court decisions,
looking at how to ensure that
national values would be guaranteed
in the police interrogation
aspect of criminal investigation.
So after many judicial cases Miranda
and its older sibling, Escobedo,
finally reversed an 1897 case
where someone had been charged
with a crime based on their
confession that we believe many,
many decades later
might have been coerced.
But actually over the
course of the 50 years
since Miranda has been decided we
have learned our constitutional
catechism in American
society through film
and TV portrayal of
the Miranda warnings.
And so it is today one of
the most well-known cases
by the American public.
Even if they don't know it by
name I think most school children
who have watched television and
film and certainly most people
in this room probably
could be qualified
to give some form of
the Miranda warnings.
And the reason I say some form is
because there also have been several
cases following the 1966 decision
that have reinterpreted, redefined
or in essence changed
perhaps the original debate
that Miranda was involved in, and
that being part of the court looking
at not wanting to - and excuse
my pun - handcuff the police
and allow someone who might
have been guilty to go free.
And on the other side people who
on the court who were concerned
that confession in general was
not the best way to prove guilt
or innocence in a criminal
proceeding.
So here we are today
and we are privileged
to have Professor Jessica
Silbey with us.
She flew in from Boston this
morning, she's flying home tonight.
She's teaching a course this summer,
so she truly is a wonder woman,
not only in her incredible
intellect,
but in just her physical stamina.
And we are privileged
because this is an area
that she has expertise in,
the law as it is reflected
in film and in media.
So I'm very anxious to
hear what she has to say
and I know all of you are, as well.
Before we do that, however, Rob
Stone, who is our Film Curator here
at the Packard Campus, has compiled
some clips that he will walk us
through to sort of warm us up
to how Miranda at least plays
out in the media, and
to please realize
that in most interrogations
rooms there is no lovely music
or high visual in the background,
and in fact that may be some
of the concerns about how Miranda
has been enforced in these 50 years
since it was first decided
by the Supreme Court.
Before turning the podium over to
Rob, however, I must give a shout
out to Tom Leighton
and to Thomson Reuters,
who have very generously
underwritten the Law Library's
full-year commemoration
of the Miranda decision,
so they are sponsoring the event
that we have had here today,
they sponsored the event that we
had a few weeks ago on Law Day,
and they will sponsor
our connection of Miranda
to Human Rights Day in December.
So thank you, Tom, and Thomson
Reuters for joining us in this very,
very important marking of a Supreme
Court decision and of American law.
Rob, if you'll come to the podium?
We will have question-and-answer
after Professor Silbey's
formal presentation
and so please keep your
questions until then,
I think there'll be adequate time.
And thank you for being here today.
Rob?
>> Robert Stone: Good afternoon.
In putting together a montage,
which is always hard to do
because you have to find a
word or two here or there,
I discovered a few things about
how Miranda rights are portrayed
in films and how they
are used or not used.
You know, some television
shows barely allude to it,
other television shows every
week you're hearing something.
The way it has evolved on television
is the first clip you're going
to see is going to be Dragnet's
1967, it was called Dragnet 1967
because it ran the '66-'67 year.
It's going to be the Big LSD
is the name of the episode.
It was the very first
episode in September of '66
that Dragnet put together, and Jack
Webb was insistent upon once the
court decision was made
that he wanted to see
at least his perception
of the reading
of rights verbatim on screen.
So that's the first thing
you're going to see,
which a bit to his
credit he continued to do
that throughout both
Dragnet and Adam 12.
You pretty much when they arrested
somebody you heard pretty much the
entire reading of someone's rights.
Very quickly it went away from that
to you'd start to hear, you know,
you did start to say the
beginning part - you have the right
to remain silent - and then
you'd kind of find away
because very quickly people
knew what they were saying
so they didn't have to put
it all on the screen for you
to know what was happening.
Then it progressed even further
from that to read him his rights.
And then you've gone to a lot of
shows, they arrest the person,
they just assume that you know that
they've been read their rights.
And then it gets to the point
to where they don't even say,
have you read them their rights,
have they been Mirandized?
So, you know, with a single
word people are supposed
to understand everything.
So some of the clips I'm going
to show you are those illusions.
There's like a promo for a show
and a clip from The Good Wife
that are those kind of, you know,
you're kind of getting it read
to people, but not totally.
But then most of the other clips I
chose to use for this clip show are
of the more humorous nature because
where we started with Jack Webb
with the whole thing being read
to now we kind of allude to it,
it's really the whole reading
somebody their rights is used
in the humorous way
probably most often nowadays.
And we can judge whether or
not that's a wise thing or not,
but that's pretty much, most
movies if they're going to talk
about Miranda they're going to
take kind of a humorous look at it.
So a lot of the clips
today are humorous,
that's kind of intentional.
But I think you'll notice the
guy that's the very last clip,
he's probably the, at least
his character was the champion
for not reading anybody any
rights much less anything else.
But, anyhow, they're short clips
so I think you'll enjoy them,
and then after I'm done Dr. Silbey
will be here to talk seriously
about the subject, so enjoy.
>> Pool boy.
>> What do you think,
Joe, cartwheels?
>> Sugar cubes.
I'll make you a book,
he's been dropping
that acid we've been hearing about.
All right, son, you're under arrest.
It's our duty to advise you
of your constitutional rights.
You have the right to remain silent
and any statements you make may be
used against you in a court of law.
You have the right to the
presence of an attorney.
If you cannot afford one, one will
be appointed before any questioning.
Do you understand that?
>> There I am.
I'm over there.
I'm not here anymore.
My hair is green and I'm a tree.
>> You ever see anybody
this torn up?
>> Well, it's a cinch he's
not strung out on sugar cubes.
>> If you can't afford
an attorney ...
>> You know I ain't
got no shirt to wear.
>> ... one of these people
will be appointed for you.
>> The blouse makes it weird.
>> No.
>> Good luck.
>> Benched.
It's Tuesday, October
28th, from USA.
>> The Department was forced to
drop the charges because you forgot
to read him his Miranda rights.
What possible reason is there for
not doing the only thing you have
to do when arresting someone?
>> I didn't read him his rights?
I did a version of that.
>> Do you even know
the Miranda rights?
>> Yes.
>> Let's hear them then?
>> Wait, we've got a
lot of stuff to do.
>> Go ahead?
You have time.
>> I think I can probably
push it back.
>> Go ahead, its four
declamatory sentences followed
by a question, a total of 57 words.
>> Okay, it's, like it obviously
starts with you have the right
to remain silent, and - and then I
think it sounds something like ...
>> You have the right
to an attorney.
>> Oh, right - you have the
right to remain - an attorney.
>> Did you say that you have
the right to be an attorney?
>> You do have the right to
be an attorney if you want to.
>> Wait, are you David
Roshaw [Assumed Spelling]?
>> Yes, [inaudible] a little bit
of a rush, if you don't mind, okay?
>> You're under arrest, okay?
>> What?
>> You have the right
to remain silent.
Anything you do or say can be
used - what's the next part?
>> As a flotation device.
[laughter] That's very funny.
I have never Mirandaed
anyone before.
>> Really?
>> Are you guys for real?
>> Can you just read
me my rights, please?
>> You have the right
to remain silent.
You have the right to
speak to an attorney.
>> Now - anything you say
can be used against you.
>> I was coming to that.
>> But that comes before
the attorney.
>> What do you mean ...
>> Before.
>> So you got the whole right to
remain silent bit and then ...
>> Then anything you say can be ...
>> Anything you say or do can be
used against you in a court of law.
>> In a court of law.
>> And then you got
the whole attorney bit
and then the bit about ...
>> Court appointed attorney ...
>> If you can't afford ...
>> That sounds good.
>> That sound good to you?
>> What kind of cops are you?
>> Please cuff the Governor.
Please take your hands
out of your pockets.
Put your hands where I can see them.
Are you on any prescription
medications?
>> You have the right
to remain silent.
Anything you say or do
can and will be used
against you in a court of law.
>> You are a dangerous
mob, and it is our job
to bust you all for being violent.
While we are here let's
state it clear.
You have the right to remain silent.
>> Right to remain silent.
[ Music ]
>> It is my pleasure to warn you.
>> And what about my Miranda rights?
You're supposed to say I have
the right to remain silent.
Nobody said I have the
right to remain silent.
>> You have the right
to remain silent,
what you lack is the capacity.
[laughter]
>> Does Escobedo ring a bell?
Miranda? I mean you must have
heard of the Fourth Amendment?
What I'm saying is
that man had rights.
>> Well, I'm all broken up
about that man's rights.
[ Applause ]
>> Jessica Silbey: That was awesome.
So, hi. I'm Jessica Silbey, and I'm
really, really pleased to be here.
I'm very, very grateful
for the invitation
from Lea [Assumed Spelling]
and Roberta and from the folks
at the Law Library and for this
wonderful tour that we just had
of the backstage of
the archives here.
I have a background, I'm a
Lawyer and a Law Professor,
but I also have a Ph.D. in
Comparative Literature and Film
and that's where I started
my academic life in a Film
and Literature Department thinking a
lot about the relationships actually
between film and literature and law,
all forms of authoritative culture,
and trying to piece
those parts together.
And so this is like
heaven to me, all of this,
this is really wonderful.
So what I'm going to talk to you
today about is the relationship
or the shaping of culture
and law together.
I was, when I started my Ph.D., and
continue to be very, very interested
in how popular consciousness,
legal consciousness is shaped
by popular art forms, such as film,
and the fact of that shaping I think
should be pretty obvious to people.
So just colloquially we say,
for example, that too much TV
or videogames is bad
for kids, for example.
Why do we say that?
Because in the main we
think it teaches children
to like fast-food rather
than healthy snacks,
to be beautiful instead of kind
and curious, to consume rather
than to make, maybe to hold
weapons rather than to build robots.
Not all popular culture
is negative, obviously.
It's not homogenous either.
But it successfully constitutes
communities of people and thought.
All forms of popular culture,
television, film, music,
they all help form us and
bind us as communities insofar
as we're both consumers and
admirers of that culture.
And so I started wondering as a
student and as a scholar what kind
of community does legal
popular culture create?
If we're to look at
mainstream films or television
about law what do they
tell us about how law is
or should be in our society?
How do they construct
our expectations
about the American justice system?
So I'm going to explore
this question with you
and trace a history of law in film.
The development, particularly,
of the trial film genre
from cinema's inception in
1894 to the present day.
And what I hope will be interesting
about this film history is
that it's not only a
story about law films,
but it's about how film is
a medium of communication
and community building, shares
certain central preoccupations
with law as a system of justice.
So you'll see that film is very well
suited to telling stories about law,
and I'll show how even in the
earliest stages film was preoccupied
with what it means to know through
sight, with the relationship
between witnessing
something and judging it.
And that these preoccupations, which
are themes throughout film and films
about law, there are both questions
that are legal, as well as filmic,
and they were embedded
in and shaped film
and film making from the beginning.
So at the end of the presentation
I'll ask some questions
about the relationship between
law and film today in courtrooms
and in police cars, on
Facebook, and how that history
of film might shed some light on
what we should be doing with film
as lawyers or judges, as members
of society serving equal
justice under the law.
So I'm going to start
with some definitions,
that's what lawyers and
teachers tend to do.
When I talk about law I'm
not talking today necessarily
about statutes or cases or
constitutions, I'm talking about -
I'm not talking about law on
the books, people would say -
I'm talking about law's popular
incarnation, which I think one
of its proudest is the trial.
Trials are that ubiquitous
symbol of law and justice
in our contemporary popular
culture, although they are
so infrequent to be fair.
And the trial is particularly
well suited to film and it's
on film all the time because
as a genre it shares some
of the general strategies
of film and of law
that is the authority grounded in
the individual's person who claims
to know and to judge the
world based on our capacity
to observe and to deliberate.
So the trial is based on
witness testimony and judging
that testimony, for example,
and documentary evidence
and film is based on
the same kind of thing.
So when I talk about film I'm not
only talking about what the film
or the video or the television
says, that is not only its content,
but I'm talking about how
it says it, the distinct way
of making meaning as primarily
visual whose significance comes
from this overdetermined
and illusory conflation
of images onscreen and
the event being filmed.
The film constructs this community
through acts of visual display,
our relationship to
what we're seeing,
and it manufactures a
coherence, that is a logic,
that what we see onscreen and
experience it as if it were part
of our world here and now.
So the story I tell will be visual.
It's a kind of vision through
film and a history in pictures
to create what I hope will
be a convincing trajectory
of the development of
law's history in film.
So let's go back to 1894 in France,
which is the beginning
of film history.
This is Auguste and Louis Lumiere,
and they developed a portable
moving picture machine in 1894.
Just a year later in December, 1895,
in the basement of the Grand Cafe
in Paris the first
movie theater opened.
Showing there were four
Lumiere films, very short,
they were called actuality films.
Among them was L'Arrivee
d'un Train en Gare,
The Arrival of a Train in a Station.
And the story goes that upon
showing of this particular film,
which is with a camera stations on
a K, and the train is growing larger
and larger onscreen as it goes
closer and closer to the station,
the audience screamed,
jumped up from their seats
and ran from the theater.
That is they were afraid that the
train was heading right for them
and they were not at all accustomed
to that illusion of reality
that film motion creates, and this
1895 audience feared for their lives
and they didn't see
the end of the film
until they came back
and were told otherwise.
So despite this aborted viewing
the French film empire was off
and running.
There was a pleasure in that
fear, in that form of witnessing,
and the notion that film had
a particularly real feel,
real and not real enabled
the audience to bear witness
to something that was
projected onscreen.
Now around 1902 this
genre of actualities,
like pseudo documentaries,
they found narrative,
and with it the reality film
of the Lumiere brothers
was replaced with fantasy.
The quintessential example is
of George Melies' early film,
A Trip to the Moon, and although his
films looked more like stage plays,
the camera tended to be passive
while actors ran on and off stage,
puppeteers moved props, the film
actually told a much more complex
story and it involved the
audience in that story.
So his 1903 film, The Magic Lantern,
this is the best I'm sure here
on this campus, I could
get a better than this
and I may be able to ask for that.
So this is The Magic Lantern and it
was his first film, it's considered
to be the first film about film
and it tells a history
of Western dramatic art.
So from left to right it shows first
a landscape painting, then a play,
and then at the end it's the image
of the newly developed
moving pictures.
And by placing film
in the trajectory
of Western representational
art Melies' film suggests
that film art is no
more or less faithful
to its subject than his painting.
He also peaks the spectators'
attention, drawing the audience
out of what's considered
passive experience of watching
to a more active role
of contributing
and to critiquing the
meaning made of film.
You all of a sudden realize you're
watching a film about a film,
about how film was artifice
just like everything else.
So being made to recognize that film
story is just one representational
scheme among others is to
acknowledge one's own complicity
in the perpetuation of the
illusion of film's omnissions.
So self-reflexivity in film, calling
attention to film's own artifice
and relying on the audience to play
along makes the audience participate
in the story being told and
that was born with Melies.
This self-reflexivity,
the recognition
of being present beyond
the representation that is
in the audience, but also
integral to the meaning
of what's onscreen is one
feature of what makes law and film
and their way of knowing and
judging the world so compatible.
It's, for example, how audience
members might experience film
as jurors might experience trials,
isolated and apart but acutely aware
of their integral role in the
justification and significance
of the spectacle before them.
Now Edwin Porter's Great Train
Robbery was also made in 1903,
but in the United States.
The Great Train Robbery
is considered one
of the first pseudo documentaries,
but it's a pseudo documentary.
And its subject was
how to rob a train.
And I kid you not there was
anxiety and fear and popularity
around this film that it was a
very effective teaching tool,
telling audiences the truth
about how to do things
or how life is or can be.
The Great Train Robbery's
other contribution
to film is its editing structure.
By juxtaposing shots of otherwise
discontinuous images the filmmaker,
Edwin Porter, creates logic
where there wasn't before.
So think about other films
the camera stayed still
and things happened in front of it
or the train, it was just a video
or a film of the train
entering the station.
This is about actually
stopping and starting the camera
and making new shots and
piecing them together.
And this phenomenon was
explained in early series
of experiments conducted in 1920
by Russian filmmaker Kuleshov
in which he juxtaposed various
scenes - here's an image
of the Kuleshov experiment
- juxtaposing the same image
of a man holding his chin with three
different shots - a bowl of soup,
a corpse, and a woman
lying in a bed.
And when he experimentally
established
that people would see the top
image and see the man as hungry,
the middle image they'd
interpret the man as sorrowful,
and the bottom image they'd
interpret him as lustful.
That is the idea that the same exact
image has different meaning based
on what comes before it.
Now this might make sense to all
of us, but this was not understood
to be how film could make
meaning and yet it was one
of the most powerful ways that
film would develop over time.
Here is Alfred Hitchcock
saying the same thing.
>> Now the third way is what
one might call pure cinematics,
the assembly of film,
and how it can be changed
to create a different idea.
Now we have a close-up
that we show what he sees.
Let's assume he saw a woman
holding a baby in her arms.
Now we cut back to his reaction
to what he sees, and he smiles.
Now what is he as a character?
He's a kindly man,
he is sympathetic.
Now let's take the middle piece of
film away, the woman with the child,
but leave his two pieces
of film as they were.
Now we'll put in a piece of
film of a girl in a bikini.
He looks, girl in a
bikini, he smiles.
What is he now?
A dirty old man.
He's no longer the benign
gentleman who loves babies.
That's what film can do for you.
>> All right, so before film was
10 years old the most important
technique was experimentally
established,
that is the human tendency
to create relationships
between otherwise totally
unrelated scenes.
We, the audience, create narrative
where none existed before,
we bring the story to the images.
This technique of montage
was made even more famous
with the filmmaker D.W Griffith.
Griffith's legacy for film and its
grammar, the close-up and deep focus
and the long shot, is profound.
Before his masterpieces of Birth
of a Nation and Intolerance
in 1907 D.W. made one of his
first appearances on film -
directors often liked putting
themselves in film in little bits
and parts - and he was
in Falsely Accused.
Falsely Accused is possibly
the first trial film.
Here's an image from the trial
scene and I'll explain it.
It contains many of the
trial film's generic markers
that remain intact today.
Falsely Accused opens with
a murder of an inventor
and the false accusation that
his daughter committed the crime.
The daughter's boyfriend dwelling
on the crime scene finds
a motion picture camera
which had miraculously been running
during the commission of the murder.
This is 1907, okay?
He develops, so it's a
film about a film, right -
he develops the film which, of
course, reveals the true murderer
and rushes it to the courthouse
where he shows it to the judge
and the jury to free his girl.
And this is an image
of the courtroom scene
where a screen is being hung
to show that piece of evidence.
It's been argued that
Falsely Accused is the genesis
of those trial films in
which the missing piece
of evidence is magically caught on
film or a photograph, for example,
which once developed
is shown to the court
in this triumphant
climax to solve the crime.
In addition to its self-referential
gesture making the film,
the star of the film around
which the meaning of the story
about law's relationship
to truth is structured,
Falsely Accused also participates
in the trial film genre
by featuring the film
audience as the jury.
So by showing the film of the
crime in court to solve the mystery
and expose the true killer
the jury within the film
and the film's audience
who already knew
that eventually share
the same information
about who committed the murder
and can render a unanimous verdict
of not guilty, releasing what would
otherwise be a substantial amount
of tension in the film.
So, thus, I suggest
this is the origin
of the audience satisfaction
that's so much
of what trial films have in them.
so here in 1907 film is both
evidence and it's a story
of evidence, it's a way of
knowing, of revelation and a story
about how one comes to know.
Many, many trial films that follow
will contain similar features.
And so already only seven years into
this new century self-reflexivity,
audience participation are
part of the film's world making
and were part of the story that
film told about law, as well.
Now after the First World War there
were two European film movements
and they developed in parallel,
one in Germany and one in Russia,
and they both worked on the same
problem which is about point
of view, that is the view
from a single narrator
with which the audience
will identify.
And this is the development
of film narrative
from what would otherwise
be omniscient tell-all,
sort of a perspective,
a God perspective,
to a much more intimate personal
story where we get to know
and experience the perspective
of subjective characters,
usually the protagonists.
So, for example, this is
an omniscient perspective,
Triumph of the Will,
Leni Riefenstahl's voice
of God perspective, and this would
be a much more subjective first
person perspective, where you
feel like you are a part of
or you are experiencing the
film story from the perspective
of one of the characters.
It is here where we find the
seeds, also, of the American hero,
the legal hero who is
autonomous and who stands apart
from the film's story
and yet is very integral
to its storytelling function.
Much like the idealized juror or
the legal hero whose independence
from law is necessary for his
right to his participation in it,
we glorify these independent
and self-reliant individuals.
His perspective might not
always be true, indeed,
it's not always true,
but we revere them.
The development of the first
person narrative capitalizes
on the film's capacity for
empathy and to identify
with these heroes creating a
sense of intimacy and revelation,
but it nonetheless does something
also which is blurring the boundary
between subjective and objective
perspectives between bias,
first person perspectives, and more
the value of unbiased or omnissions.
The first person narrative
problematizes,
speaking from one perspective,
problematizes the ability to know
through sight because it depends
on who does the seeing or telling,
whose view is the audience privy to?
This is not unlike the challenge
of credibility determinations made
in trial courts regularly
regarding witness testimony.
So this problem of a first
person narration actually started
with German expressionism
from 1919 to 1933 about,
and after D.W. Griffith's
close-up, which signifies intimacy,
sometimes intrusion, that
close-up was transformed into sort
of psychological drama where the
film could mirror the subjective
feelings of a single character,
making room for distortion
and deception.
So this is The Cabinet of
Dr. Caligari from 1920,
and it is one of these films
in which the audience thinks
it's being told a tragic story
but true story about
the main character
from that main character's
experience, who turns out in the end
to be telling us a
deluded and paranoid fable
from inside a mental institution.
At the other extreme of the same
movement and style is Fritz Lang's M
from 1931, and this is the
story of a serial killer played
by Peter Lorre whose perspective
on the floundering
investigation haunts the audience.
It's always from his perspective
that we're seeing things,
so much so that when he cries
out at the end of the film,
who knows what it's like to
be me, he yells that directly
at the camera, only the
audience really feels
like we know what it's
like to be him.
And this is a notorious
trial film actually,
not because it depicts
any legal system actually,
but because it tells the
story of mob justice.
The legal system is usurped
by mobs in this film,
outlaws taking the rein
of law for good or for ill
and this becomes a familiar
paradigm in the following decades.
So during this technical and
naratological revolution from 1895
to about 1930 we have montage
editing, first person narrative,
sound eventually shows up.
This is the story of The
Jazz Singer from October 6th,
1927 on Broadway was the first
performance of a sound film.
And so you have to imagine that
all these movies, all these images,
all this cultural capital
is spinning for two decades,
three decades without
audible words coming
out of the mouths of the actors.
The pleasure of images strung
together and their capacity
to build instant and compelling
communities was so powerful
that words were unnecessary,
the pictures they sufficed.
So from the late 1930s to 1950s
when the United States is
growing more politically powerful
and economically powerful
and dominant
in the world Hollywood also became
the cultural center of film.
Hollywood learned from its
European masters and Fritz Lang,
he comes to the United States and he
makes a film, Like Fury, from 1936.
Big Heat he also made in 1953.
And these films, both law
and chaos kind of films,
although Fury is the trial film,
they bookend what we call the Film
Noir period, which is characterized
by Cerio Skero's black-and-white
style of filmmaking
and a criminal underside
of post-war glory
of American life and institutions.
So let me tell you about Fury.
It's one of my favorite films.
So it stars Spencer Tracy as Joe
Wilson, who is wrongfully accused
of kidnapping, and when
detained he is presumably killed
by this mob outside the jailhouse,
who sets fire to his jail cell.
And the audience sees his
face through the flames.
I couldn't get the
picture of the flames,
but the flames eventually come.
And his burning face and
eventual confirmation of his death
in the newspapers in the
films are showed to us.
And yet we know that he survives,
but only we know he survives.
So here are the film within
the film, the newspapers
and the newsreel footages
that's shown in court.
Here again is the court
scene with the scrim going
up to the show the film of him, of
the flames devouring him in jail.
It looks a lot like the court
scene from Falsely Accused, right?
Which shows all of these film
and newsreels shows his demise.
They actually fail to reveal
the truth, because Joe survives,
and they perpetuate
the lie of Joe's death.
So the film is pointing to
itself here, but in its moment
of self-reflection it's revealing
an untruth and that's the clue
to how law in this film
will fail to serve justice.
So he seeks revenge, he seeks
revenge for his near death,
but instead of entrusting the
legal system with his exoneration
of kidnapping he manipulates the
district attorney and he conspires
with his brothers here
in the conviction
of the mob for his murder.
Now when the film jury is about
to convict those in the crowd
who set the fire he
dramatically enters the courtroom,
another exciting climax,
and halts the trial.
This film marks the beginning
of two decades of legal films
that criticize law's
capacity for justice.
It is further evidence
of this liberal legal
subject as a legal hero.
He's positioned antithetical to
and outside of the law, Joe Wilson,
but he nevertheless participates in
the system to right the institution
that has strayed from its goal.
These are sort of like
legal cowboys,
alienated from the formal
legal system by choice or force
who eventually are brought back
to or return to see justice done.
While criticizing the legal
system for failing its subjects,
the legal hero will add
strength to that system
by showing here how truth and
justice through law depends
on the participation of
righteous individuals.
Film from this ilk are plentiful,
from this era are plentiful,
so well-known films include
Young Mr. Lincoln by John Ford,
The Paradine Case by
Alfred Hitchcock.
It's also the time that Hollywood,
as I said, is growing more
and more dominant and Classical
Hollywood Style is taking
over from Film Noir.
Really Classical Hollywood Style
in the '50s and '60s is an anecdote
to Film Noir, and some of the most
famous Hollywood trial films were
made during this time.
And by famous I mean that they're
still referred to as providing
that template for the
courtroom genre,
creating some of the most
memorable characters onscreen.
I'm sure many of you can name them
by heart, and they're commenting
on the American legal system that
was actually evolving at this time
to accommodate the
development of civil liberties.
These are films that in contrast
to the skepticism from the '20s,
'30s and '40s pervaded
that time period,
portray now a more hopeful
vision of the legal system.
So this is Adam's Rib, for example,
path breaking film for women,
one of the few comedic trial
films also, 12 Angry Men,
Sidney Lumet's masterpiece
glorifying the jury process,
and the contribution of every
person to Law's Endeavor.
Compulsion, in which Orson
Welles plays Clarence Darrow
in the Loeb-Leopold case and
delivers what has been reported
to be the longest speech at
15 minutes to a film audience
in one clip, breaking with
the fiction of the film
and directly addressing the audience
about the horrors of
the death penalty.
Inherit the Wind, Stanley
Kramer's rendition
of the Scopes monkey trial.
To Kill a Mockingbird,
Gregory Peck brings
to life Harper Lee's Atticus Finch
and dramatizes the complicity
of the American legal
system with the personal
and social tragedies of Jim Crow.
So while Hollywood was creating and
distributing these memorable stories
and heroes of American justice
and the pursuit of truth,
French filmmakers,
what were they doing?
Francois Truffaut and Jean-Luc
Godard were classifying film,
they were starting to critique
film, this is the '60s, after all,
about how film particularly
makes meaning.
The mechanical means of photographic
reproduction they say lulled us
into a false sense of objectivity.
Concern with just how this false
objectivity would translate
into narrative and to politics.
The study of film in the 1960s
began with the critical capacity
to examine films illusory
coherence between the thing on film
and the thing being filmed.
We've gone right back to 1895.
We see courtroom justice, but
what we see is not what is,
it's one story among many we
could tell and experience,
but the experience of seeing it
makes us believe in its possibility.
The question is how real?
French theorists wrote that film
is an instrument of ideology,
and that was the beginning of
the study of media studies,
communication studies,
film studies and in
that way constituting its subject.
Film constitutes us, whether it be
law or a kind of hero or a community
through this mechanism of seeing and
being seen, witnessing and judging.
And the illusory sense
of omniscience,
but from our perspective at
the center of the story is
in fact what Classical
Hollywood film depends on,
this coherent narration,
a good story by a psychologically
defined individual
as the principal causal
agent of justice.
The film enables narrative
coherence, that is that good story
through our act of watching it
and desiring a certain reassurance
and control at the end, affirming
our sense of a certain kind of order
and a certain kind of understanding
based on seeing with our own eyes.
The story of law that these films
tell is entirely fictional and
yet it lives in our culture.
It is real in that way, part of
our collective consciousness,
and it cultivates - that's what
the French theorists said -
expectations, emotions and desires.
So how does this work in
the films that followed?
Consider more recent films, like
Erin Brockovich, North Country,
both squarely in this film tradition
echoing stories of this ideology
of the central independent
individual who brings us along
in their story and whose skepticism
of law and marginalization is undone
by the experience of revelation
in and through the legal process.
Truth is revealed through law and
on film, hear of the liability
of polluters or of sexual harassers.
Consider how many trial films
like this are combinations of sort
of a docudrama based on a true
story and Classical Hollywood film,
two genres that will best perpetuate
an idealistic, perhaps naive view
of film's capacity and law's
ability to reveal the truth.
These are typical films in that
they triumph the independent
and determined fair-minded citizen,
answering in the affirmative
the question about whether
that lone individual, the
legal hero, the every person
who is devoted and idealistic.
Think not only of Charleze Theron
and Julia Roberts' character,
but John Travolta in a Civil
Action, Paul Newman in The Verdict,
both based on true stories.
Or more fictional but
equally forceful,
Tom Cruise in A Few Good Men,
Denzel Washington in Philadelphia,
George Clooney in Michael Clayton.
These legal heroes prevail
in tainted legal systems
by making a difference
through determined
and against all odds participation.
The lawyers are protagonists in
these films, are everyday heroes,
they're David's and Goliath's
system, and the story is of access,
of opportunity, of fairness
no matter who you are
and where you came from - it's an
American story, an ideal to be sure.
You should have noticed that most
of these legal heroes are white men.
Interestingly enough, sometime
in the 1990s American trial films
started casting more lawyers
and judges as African-American
and as women,
presenting a much more hopeful
picture of an enlightened future
where positions of power in the
judicial system are open to all,
again, constituting a hopeful
community of inclusion.
By contrast judges who are
shortsighted at this time
or portrayed as crazy, there are a
lot of bored and eccentric judges
in these films, are often old and
Caucasian, telling another story
about where the weak link
in our systems might lie.
There are many iconic trial films
that are based on true stories,
making this ideology of
American independent minded
and determined hero even more
authoritative, even more persuasive.
And although many films are
not self-explicitly referential
in their symbolism it's not uncommon
for the legal investigation leading
to the trial film's climax in
these films to be structured
around a visual revelation,
uncovering a missing document,
a smoking gun, the critical word,
discovering a missing identity.
So film's indicia of truth,
achieving a just verdict
through visual revelation
only furthers film's
authoritative message.
It's a way of conveying it
by convincing the audience
that seeing is knowing
and witnessing is power,
which in turn should
facilitate justice.
Think of other classic
courtroom dramas
that are based on true stories.
Anatomy of a Murder, Inherit the
Wind, People vs. Larry Flynt,
Young Mr. Lincoln, Judgment
at Nuremburg, The Verdict.
These true stories are
not necessarily popular
because they're true, but because
they exemplify through 100 years
of cinema the central ties
that bind film world making
to legal world making.
From the Lumiere brothers' actuality
films, where audience members ran
from the theater worried the
train would run them down,
to docudramas like The Civil Action
where viewing audiences are made
to worry, to really worry that the
legal system is not sufficiently
capacious to condemn polluters
who cause illness and death.
These films play on the question
of how do we know what we know,
how do we decide we know what we do,
and the law's relationship to both.
Ultimately they're about the duty
and difficulty of judging
as citizens.
The roots of early film are in
these docudramas, they unify sight
with knowledge, which is an issue
of evidence, and ways of knowing
as seeing and being seen by each
other, which is about judging
and objectivity and the importance
of each individual's perspective.
This I would say shows the
root of law in early film.
I could tell you the same
story about television,
which has three main variations.
There are Law and Order
type police serials,
which revolve around
investigative teams and end
with revelation usually of guilt
after hard, courageous work
and a lot of rule breaking,
despite the ubiquity
of Miranda warnings we saw
those rule breaking there,
gratuitous police procedure
and paperwork.
The most recent incarnation of
this genre is True Detective,
talk about guilt and rule breaking,
if you haven't already seen it,
ends in this climatic
confrontation with evil.
One of my favorites in the
new version is How to Get Away
With Murder, the award winning
Viola Davis playing this liminal,
edgy hero, who can dazzle in
court with her team and plays law
like an exquisite instrument
towards the ends
that she believes to be just.
And yet we tend to agree because
we're so impressed with her,
and she's part of the second
type of legal television show,
which is the law firm serial -
Damages, Boston Legal, The Practice,
Ally McBeal, L.A. Law,
The Good Wife, Suits.
All the same kind of show in
which law is this game played
by skilled actors, who
we trust or love or not,
mostly because of their
character and judgment.
Law is just a sport in these
films or in these TV shows,
and we root for the winners who are
winners, not because of their causes
but because of their character, whip
smart, hardworking, independent.
The third kind of television genre
are reality shows and court TV --
Peoples Court, Judge Judy,
The O.J. Trial Then and Now.
Making of a Murderer, the
documentary serial which is hard
to watch, if you haven't
yet, because it's hard
to believe can police be
so corrupt, so flawed?
We need really only look
around to recent events.
Forced to ask is reality on
TV or is TV making reality?
When courtroom television first
began we debated this so-called CSI
affect, are audiences so
lulled by what they see
that once we participate in actual
legal procedure it will distort us,
we will distort or it will
be distorted or mismanaged
through our expectations.
Do people watch Judge Judy
or did they watch Judge Ito
and think this is what
courts are, in fact, like?
When you turn on a camera in an
interrogation room, for example,
or you film a documentary
about a murder investigation do you
think you're not altering the events
that are being filmed?
Are you not becoming the part
of the story that's being told?
The thin blue line famously
created a whole new trial
for the defendant in that case.
The paradox at the heart of Making
a Murderer is the same thing.
The podcast sensation, the
serial, the same thing.
It's also at the heart of the debate
concerning cameras in the courtroom.
Film and law collapsed
together as joined ways
of telling the most definitive
truth we can say about our world.
Truth matters to law and to the
confidence in our justice system,
if not also to our democracy,
but truth is not easy to see,
it's not easy to see,
and it's rarely on film
or television as hard
as we may look.
What we see are myths and ideals
and nightmares and the truths
of our lives together
is much more complex
than a video image or a film story.
So after the past weeks I have to
say after Saint Paul and Baton Rouge
and of Dallas it bears
repeating that policing
and legal decision-making is
increasingly involving film,
documentary like film, films
that compete for truth claims
about police brutality, racism
and the justified use of force.
Bystander videos of police
brutality don't answer the question
of whether the police were motivated
by racism and unjustified fear.
We come to these films,
videos of police brutality
or videotaped confessions
of guilt, for example,
with preconceived notions already
about the justice or injustice
of the event they portray.
When I look at films of the
killing of Philando Castile
and Alton Sterling I see
excusable murder, but I know enough
about US culture and film to know
that not everyone sees
what I see in those videos.
Likewise, filmed interrogations,
filmed confessions, dash cams,
bodycams, what story do they tell?
The early film masters would ask
whose story do they tell and how?
Like most documentaries they do
not tell us what really happened.
If there is an incontestable
and singular account, at all,
but as visual narratives they're
particularly good at persuading us
of a point of view and they can
contextualize claims to truth.
They can help us tell a bigger
story, a more complex one.
But, of course, the film
is not the whole truth.
It does, however, participate
in culture
as if it needs no explanation.
But films need a lot of explanation.
Letting films speak for themselves
is leaving the world they create
in other people's hands.
So I cannot resist,
because I'm a Law Professor,
to talk about a case in
my last five minutes.
The case is Scott vs. Harris
from 2007, and at the center
of this case was a video of a
car chase taken from the dash cam
of a police cruiser that
was pursuing a suspect.
And the video shows the
police officer racing
down this dark narrow road
and deliberately ramming the
suspect's car to end the chase.
The suspect was paralyzed as a
result of the crash and the issue
to be decided was whether or not
the police officer was justified
in the use of force
to end the car crash.
As you can imagine,
the focal evidence
in the case was the dash cam
video, and it went all the way
up to the Supreme Court and at
oral argument both Justices Breyer
and Scalia vocalized this power
of film that I've been talking
about for the past 40 minutes, this
power of film and their naive belief
that film captures reality, at least
the relevant legal reality at hand.
Justice Breyer noted, his
voice raised if you listen
to the oral argument, he says I
see with my own eyes what happened,
what am I supposed to do?
And Justice Scalia exclaimed that
the video of the car chase was one
of the scariest he'd seen
since The French Connection.
So sure was Scalia of his and the
court majority's interpretation
of the video as justifying the use
of force because the chase looked
so dangerous to them
that in a footnote
to the opinion Justice
Scalia invited the readers
to watch the video for themselves.
So he says far from
being the cautious
and controlled driver
the lower court depicts,
they overturned the lower court,
what we see on the video more
closely resembles a Hollywood style
car chase and the most frightening
sort, placing police officers
and innocent bystanders alike
at great risk of serious harm.
And then he says we're happy
to allow the videotape
to speak for itself.
I read that and just groaned.
Justice Stevens was the
lone dissenter in this case,
and he took the majority to task
for disregarding the lower
court's factual findings based
on all the evidence before it,
evidence that included much more
than the film, driving conditions,
common speeds on the particular
stretch of road, the experience
of police officers, the
suspect's known criminal record.
And particularly he complained his
colleagues had never clearly driven,
had clearly never driven on
a dark country road before.
He says it's not a scary speeding
car chase, he says, it's normal.
He says I can only conclude that my
colleagues were unduly frightened
by two of the three images on
the tape that looked like bursts
of lightning or explosion, but
were in fact merely the headlights
of vehicles zooming by
in the opposite lane.
Had they learned to drive when
most high-speed driving took place
on two lane roads rather
than on superhighways,
when split second judgment is about
the risk of passing a slowpoke
in the face of oncoming
traffic were routine,
they might well have reacted to
the videotape more dispassionately.
So, in other words, he says don't
just fall victim to the effects
on screen, consider the evidence
that can contextualize what you see.
He does what many film
and cultural critics do,
he asks how the film's portrayal of
the event is being shaped and coaxed
by particular experiences and
points of view, a bird's eye view
on the dashboard, for
example, rather than from above
or alongside the car, which would
have given you a very different
sense of how fast the car was going
and how dangerous things were.
A long shot rather than a close-up
would have made all the difference
in this video.
He manifests a healthy
skepticism towards film that claims
to depict the truth
or speaks for itself.
He does not disregard the film,
that's an important point,
he just understands its power and
its relevance and he simply asks
that all other evidence be
considered, not just the film alone.
So he does not fall
victim to the illusion
of reality that the film portrays.
He did not repeat the mistake
of that first film audience,
as experiencing film as reality
unraveling in front of his eyes.
So film very persuasively constructs
a world for us, a compelling,
sometimes loveable, sometimes scary
world, but film like all other forms
of communication - it can be
photography, oral testimony,
drawings, it can be
Twitter, Snapchat, e-mail -
all of it is a kind of language
that must be interpreted,
it must be scrutinized,
it has to be evaluated.
It must be cross-examined, actually,
to understand what it really
means for the case at hand.
So the history of law and film
and television is really an
idealized story of heroes
and villains, easy-to-identify
corruption,
and quick procedural fixes
to avoid future injustices.
That is not the world we live in.
Film can tell very potent stories
and may foster civic engagement
or social change on their own.
They are very, very powerful forms
of communicating and world building,
but we need much more than
these beloved characters
or shocking images to
fulfill this promise
of equal justice under the law.
Films get the story going, they
plant seeds, but it's really
up to the collective work
of communities committed
to human flourishing to
make sure that the story
that the film began ends well.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Roberta Shaffer: Thank
you, Professor Silbey,
that was fascinating and a wonderful
proof of the thesis of The Library
of Congress, that we have to look
across the disciplines
to find insight.
We'd like to open the
floor for questions.
We'll have a roving mike,
so if you'll raise your hand
when you would like to ask a
question we can then bring the mike
to you and we can capture
it on our tape.
So there's a question
right here that I see.
>> Hi. A wonderful lecture,
Jessica, I really appreciated it.
I'm just wondering if you've
thought about the role
of the legal technical advisor
in the making of law films,
what their ethical
responsibilities might be,
what is the role they have,
whether they actually play a
positive role or a negative role?
I'm just wondering if
you've thought about that?
>> Jessica Silbey: Are you
talking about the folks who consult
like on The Good Wife
and stuff like that?
>> Yes, exactly.
>> Jessica Silbey: Right, I've
always wanted to be one of those.
>> My former trial partner
in the Cook County State's Attorney
is the consultant on The Good Wife.
>> Jessica Silbey: Okay.
>> And I've done it myself.
>> Jessica Silbey: I think I
might remember you saying that.
So I find The Good Wife to be one of
- I love The Good Wife in large part
because they often
get the law right,
although in very truncated
form, that is the questions
that they're wrestling
with are actual -
they resonate with real questions
I would talk about in class.
So the role of the technical
advisor, so ethical duties?
So I would hate to say that
I think popular culture needs
to be accurate all the time, I
think that's sort of a silly -
I wouldn't want to say that, but
there are films, ones that claim
to be true or based on true
stories that take liberties
that I feel do harm, can do harm.
And in those films I've
been part of debates
that I understand both
sides of, so documentaries
that are clearly advocacy
documentaries and aren't evenhanded
and they have experts that
say, you know, you don't have
to be evenhanded, you're
telling the truth,
you're just not giving both sides.
I think it's like a bad form
of teaching, for example,
but I don't think there's an
ethical obligation to be evenhanded.
And what I tell my students is that
documentaries don't pretend to be -
I mean you can't, how do
you tell the whole truth?
Documentaries are films, when you
go to court you have a legal trial,
there are all different
ways to portray truths.
But you can see how it
facilitates the power
of visuals over everything else.
And so one of the things that
upsets me or I get concerned
about in the dominance
of visual images
as this truth telling mechanism
is when we get police videos,
for example, which just take over
all other forms of rational thought.
And that makes me nervous.
I wish it wouldn't be the case.
I don't think it has to be the case,
but I think we lend ourselves -
we go down that path when we
lose our critical capacity.
What I just want to say is I
think most of us go to film,
we go to the movies or we watch TV,
and we have critical capacities.
We're film critics all the
time, like that was a bad one
or they should have done that
or why did they end that way?
We say that all the time
as consumers of culture,
but sometimes when there's this
truth veneer, a documentary
or a dash cam, we lose
that critical capacity
and I'm very interested
in that slippage.
And I think when that
slippage is possible I feel
like there's more ethical
obligations
to bring one's attention
back to the critical.
>> At heart, in most courtroom
dramas, they're mysteries
and I think that's one reason
why it's so appealing to us.
And there's a narrative, information
is withheld, we are typically not,
you know, there might be
an omniscient narrator
who knows everything but
only reveals information
to us in little packets.
I was glad you included that
little clip of Alfred Hitchcock
because he was the master of that.
>> Jessica Silbey:
Of withholding, yes.
>> Withholding that information, but
at the same time is there a tension
between the narrative impetus of the
filmmaker and I put it in quotes,
accurate portrayal of the law?
>> Jessica Silbey: So the first
thing I think of when you say
that is when you go to trial
or you're negotiating documents
for discovery you're
constantly withholding things,
you're constantly trying
to negotiate,
like what story am I going to tell
and what information do I not
want the other side to have
so they can't tell
a different story.
So legal negotiation and the
relationship of law, legal process,
to truth is as contorted
as Hitchcock's narratives.
And that's something that
we just need to accept.
Law is rarely about revealing truths
as much as it's a fair process,
it's supposed to be a fare
process of competing truths
that somebody then judges
as which one is better.
So I think withholding information
is not - I mean it's essential
to being rational at
some level, you know?
They say people who are
crazy know too much, right?
So I think film, and
Hitchcock gets it right,
he would have been a great lawyer.
>> I'm not an attorney, but when I'm
watching TV shows I often see things
that I say, you know,
that just wouldn't happen,
its illegal or whatever.
Are there any particular things
that you wish they would
stop doing and get right?
>> Jessica Silbey: Well, from the
perspective of teaching students
who are going to be lawyers I
think I resent most the drama
and the flash of so many of the
lawyers that are on TV and in film.
Being a lawyer you read
and you write and you sit
with documents all the time,
like you are a librarian
most of the time.
And I think there's a lot of
dissatisfaction in the profession
because of that dissonance.
You can be a change agent, you
can absolutely be a counselor
and an advisor, and you
see that on television
and popular culture,
doing good things.
But the time it takes, the span of
lifetime, and I tell the stories
of the Civil Rights movement, how
Thurgood Marshall started in 1920
and didn't make until 1956 -
like it takes a whole lifetime
to make those kind of
changes and on television it's
like 43 minutes, you know?
So the drudgery of lawyering,
I wish that there was -
I mean that's not a good TV
show, but the pace of law films
and law television is very distorted
and I think it gives us a sense
of impatience, which
I don't think is good
and I think lawyers
need to be very patient.
>> Hello. Comparing shows like
Boston Legal and Good Wife,
of course, are the question, but
I'm always interested in issues.
Boston Legal had very deep
issues all over the board.
Are there any specific
issues that you would think
of that are strongly often
omitted and there are the ones
that are almost every
TV show or movie.
>> Jessica Silbey: Omitted?
>> Omitted, yes?
>> Jessica Silbey: So this
is just my own bias speaking,
and so one of the reasons I love
The Good Wife for parts of it is
because they had some
intellectual property cases on there
that were done really well.
And so if you look at where legal
practice is and how it's changing.
So patent law, people weep with
boredom, but I mean it's a huge,
huge important practice for
access to medicine, for robots
and artificial intelligence and it's
the future of all the technology
that we have seen in this building
and there's no way they're going
to have a show about patent cases.
So that's not talked about.
I think The Good Wife
it was a copyright case,
it was a music copyright case
of all things, that's very sexy.
And, you know, trust and
estates, like basic family law,
I mean there are a lot of
wills and stuff like that,
but it's not the way
lawyers can be really helpful
on a day-to-day basis, the way a
general practitioner can be helpful
on a day-to-day basis, you don't see
that in films, TV shows about law
and that's where lawyers
can be really helpful
and not just everyday consulting,
but that's not dramatic.
But I would have loved
to see stuff like that.
>> Roberta Shaffer:
Jessica, I had a question.
>> Jessica Silbey: Yes?
>> Roberta Shaffer: I think
you opened the door on this,
so I'm not feeling too
bad about asking it.
But could you make a personal
comment about your feeling
about cameras in the courtroom?
>> Jessica Silbey: Oh, yes.
So my view has changed on
this actually over time.
I used to think that it would have
been a really, really good thing
to open up all courtrooms
to the cameras,
especially the Supreme Court.
It annoys me that they're
one of the last to hold out.
And I no longer feel that way.
I think being there in
person, listening to the audio,
reading the transcript,
everything is digitized,
you can get real-time transcripts,
you can hear oral arguments,
I think that might engage with the
questions of law from the audience
in a richer way right now.
I am scared about the
power of visuals
to over determine people's
lives today.
And so I feel like technology
is ahead of our own capacity
for judgment a lot of the time,
and so I'm not in favor of cameras
in all courtrooms at the moment.
There was a controversial decision
in Massachusetts a couple months ago
where some testimony,
the courtroom was open
and there was videotaped
testimony and a lot
of the testimony was
sealed because people were
in the courtroom using their
phones to record what was going on,
which is okay and yet a lot
of that testimony was really
hurtful or really upsetting.
And the judge just closed
it down because afraid
of that testimony just
getting out there in the world.
Now it's already out there
in the world, anyone can walk
into that courtroom
and see the testimony
but there was something different
about it being digitally reproduced
and then on every social
media platform in the country.
And there is a difference in kind
in that, and if I was testifying
and knew that was possible
I'd feel differently.
And I think the courtroom has to be
about the people whose interests are
involved first before anything else.
So I've changed my mind about that.
>> Hi. Do you have any particular
films that you find have changed --
so when I think of a film like Jaws
I now am scared to go in the water.
>> Jessica Silbey: Yes, right.
>> It has completely shifted the
mindset of many of us I think,
and do you find that there are films
that have distorted law so much
that it takes the law
profession a long time to recover,
like it takes a long time for
me to go back into the water?
Because it scared us so
much or changed the view?
>> Jessica Silbey: Yes.
No, it's a good question.
I don't know if I - I think
about them as collections
of films and not as any one.
But you're right about Jaws,
you're right about that.
>> It takes a long time to
recover from that experience.
>> Jessica Silbey: Right.
>> It's out there for
20, 30 years now.
>> Jessica Silbey: So I mean, right
- I mean there are styles of film
about the criminal defendant,
the wrongfully accused
criminal defendant,
for example, that people talk about.
I haven't written about this, but
other people have, that that story
of the wrongfully accused was part
of the impetus behind
innocent project
and criminal defense movements.
And so that it's not that it's
had time - you had to get over it,
but that it - the commentary
actually provided the fuel for some
of these other movements.
I have to think - I don't know
if other people have thoughts
on law movies that
are scarring that way?
Dead Man Walking, oh, didn't change
death penalty stuff here, no.
Yes, yes, oh, that's a good movie.
I sometimes have clips from Dead Man
Walking in presentations like this
because the perspectives
Dead Man Walking uses,
the camera shoots the execution both
from the side through the glass,
but also from the top of
the ceiling when he's dying,
so you have these different
- I'm getting goosebumps -
you have these different
perspectives on who is watching
at that moment and it's really good.
I'd love to hear favorite
films from you all.
>> Roberta Shaffer: Why don't you
shout out some favorite legal films
that you have or memorable ones?
>> Shawshank.
>> Jessica Silbey:
Oh, Shawshank is good,
wrongfully accused, there you go.
>> Thin Blue Line.
>> Jessica Silbey: Thin
Blue Line is really good,
taught in so many classes all over.
It's really good.
>> Anatomy.
>> Jessica Silbey:
Anatomy of a Murderer,
based on a true story, yes.
Upper Peninsula Michigan, anybody
from Upper Peninsula Michigan?
Yes.
>> Roberta Shaffer: Any others?
>> I have a question about ...
>> Jessica Silbey:
Wait, you need a mike.
>> Roberta Shaffer: Justice Delayed.
>> I was a huge Good Wife fan,
too, and I was curious it seemed
like all the judges were so quirky.
Not all of them, but many
of them had these strange,
you know, like in my opinion.
>> Jessica Silbey: Right.
>> And is that typical, I mean?
>> Jessica Silbey: Judges
are - so if you were to plot
out the characters in trial
films it's either lawyer focused,
in which case the lawyer is
reasonable and the judges are crazy,
or it's the other way around, the
judges are the reasonable people
and the lawyers are crazy.
It's rarely both of those things at
the same time, except in very few.
So in In Justice for All, for
example, that's the one I showed you
with the judge with the gun,
everyone is crazy in that film.
But they're often opposed
to one another,
which I think is interesting.
It's much easier, so often
the judge is a telltale sign
of how the law is going to
work, so if the judge is a woman
or is not white for example,
often the - this is post 1980 -
like the courtroom is a good place
to be, fairness will resolve.
I mean it's sort of interesting, you
now start watching and you'll see
that that's totally true.
And it's even true in
The Good Wife actually,
they're usually like the win signs.
>> I watch a lot of British legal
dramas, do you have a comparison
between the way they
treat law and US shows?
>> Jessica Silbey: No, I'm
totally ignorant of them.
Which are your favorite?
>> Oh, I'm trying to ...
>> Jessica Silbey: I mean there
are people devoted to them, I know,
I'm not, I just don't - not
an expert in them, at all.
It's so different, I mean
the people talk about Witness
for the Prosecution as one
of these great trial films.
I didn't feature it here.
It's a completely different way of
understanding the adversary process
and because the adversary
process is so part of the story
of the legal hero that I'm
telling, the American legal hero,
it's very different in Britain.
But I'd be interested
for the comparison.
How come you like them so much?
>> Well, I just find it interesting
to see a different system
and where the prosecutor and
the defense attorney are sort
of seated together and the
defendant is standing up in a box.
>> Jessica Silbey: Yes, right.
>> And the judge has a wig.
>> Jessica Silbey: Right.
>> Well, so did the ...
>> Jessica Silbey: Right,
it's a very different cast
of characters and intentions.
>> The prosecutors can be
defense attorneys in other trials.
>> Jessica Silbey:
Right, right, right,
it sets up different plot lines.
>> Given what you said a few
minutes ago about your concerns
about the power of video in today's
world, can you envision a framework
in which bodycam film, particularly
worn by police officers,
can be made a healthy
addition to the legal system?
>> Jessica Silbey: Yes, I
mean I think it could today.
I mean even I watch so I have an
almost 12 year old and an eight
and a half year old, and the way
they communicate through computers
and text is so much more
sophisticated than I do,
although I've been living
with it a lot longer.
And so I have a lot of faith
that people who are grown
into the new technologies understand
the nuances a lot better than people
who are learning it
like a second language.
And so I do think that - I mean
the problem is that law is an old
and conservative profession.
The people who are doing the most
important judging prosecution cases
usually are not using the
most sophisticated tools
or the technologists.
And so I think, I can imagine it
because I think eventually
all the people
who are making those decisions
will have experienced technology
as a first language rather
than - or visual technology
than a second language.
What I have advocated
and I've worked
on are whenever video
evidence or, yes,
mostly video evidence is admitted
that you have very strict rules
of how juries are instructed on it
or how judges are instructed on it
or where all the outtakes are.
You just have to learn to
ask the right questions
about what you're seeing,
and that's just not something
that most people understand to ask.
Best practices, for example, would
be that when you have a dash cam
or when you have police video that
you have more than one on the scene.
Most of the time --
there are several,
several cases where from
one angle what looks
like a gun is actually a phone,
for example, and you can see
that clearly from the
different perspective,
from a different camera placed.
Knowing that that is
important is just part of how
to use the visual technology
smartly, but not knowing
to ask about that is a problem.
So I do, I think it will
happen, just slowly.
>> Hi. I'm sorry.
Are you familiar with the film,
The Exorcism of Emily Rose?
>> Jessica Silbey: No.
>> It's sort of based on
an anthropological study
of the exorcism of Anneliese Michel.
But I was curious, particularly with
one of the comments that you made
about each one of us being a critic,
there's a scene where there's sort
of an adversarial role between an
anthropologist and psychiatrist
and they're sort of weighing I
guess the testimony that's being
offered there.
And I was wondering if
you could possibly talk
about how a judge interprets
or makes a hierarchical call
on the sort of testimony
that's offered?
So a lot of times we think of
anthropology and humanities sort
of people see them as lighter as
opposed to hard science, medicine.
>> Jessica Silbey: Yes.
>> And I figure with your background
in literature you could probably ...
>> Jessica Silbey: Right.
No, I appreciate the comment.
Right. So judges will instruct all
evidence should be treated the same
unless, you know?
I mean there's instruction on the
non-hierarchy of certain things,
but of course and we believe that
juries follow those instructions.
I think what you're suggesting is we
come to the judgment mode with all
of these other preconceived ideas
of the hierarchy of knowledge and,
right - so that one of the
things I am very worried
about is the privilege
that's given certain forms
of evidence over others.
So you'll have a video and then
you'll have a live witness saying
something different about the
video, and the video always wins.
Why is that?
Well, because witnesses
can lie and videos can't.
Well, that's just not
the way it works.
Videos don't lie, they don't have
intent, but they're not always clear
as to what they mean and they
might mean something very different
if you had figured out what
came before and what came after.
And the example I give is
videotaped confessions, so this is -
to answer your question - so
here is psychological evidence,
experimental evidence where
you have a confession,
a videotaped confession
that's filmed straight on,
just the person speaking
to the camera.
The confession is perceived
as truthful and voluntary.
You have the same exact
confession filmed from an angle
with including one of the
interrogators, so it's an angle
and you see half of a
face of the interrogator,
that same exact confession
is perceived
as less voluntary and less truthful.
It's the exact same confession.
So that kind of evidence, that kind
of experimental evidence should
debunk the hierarchy of -
because then you could have the
witness saying what I said I didn't
mean or I didn't exactly say it
that way, but they're not going
to believe you because they
see the straight on confession.
But that kind of evidence can be
very powerful to undermine it.
>> I was just going to mention
one of my favorite films,
it's not really a trial film,
it's more an evidence film,
The Conversation, Francis
Ford Coppola film.
>> Jessica Silbey:
Oh, yes, that's great.
>> It kind of ties into
what you were just saying.
>> Jessica Silbey: Yes,
that's a great film, yes.
>> Could you explain a little bit
to the audience who is not familiar
with the film why is
it significant that -
the amount of information he
gets draws one conclusion,
and then as he continues
to fill in the gaps ...
>> Jessica Silbey: The gaps you draw
a completely different conclusion.
This is a lot like - it's the
style of Roshomon, if people know
that story, that film,
Akira Kurosawa, where -
this is really just a
story that you hear pieces
and then you get more information
and all of a sudden your idea
of what the story is about and
how it's going to end changes.
Kurosawa's film was the same thing,
it's the story of a murderer told
by one person and you're
completely convinced,
and then told from the
perspective of a different person
and it's a completely different
story but it's about the same event.
And then you're told a third story
that sounds completely different
about the same event that gives
you a different idea of guilt
and innocence and liability.
And Kurosawa made that
film in '80, 1980?
>> 1950.
>> Jessica Silbey: 1950, yes,
I was thinking '80 is wrong.
So that the idea of withholding,
back to the conversation
about withholding, about what
is the whole truth, you know,
the difference between what we
hear, the narrative, and what we see
versus what actually happened.
All of those film questions on
a regular basis, film questions,
and ironically the way film is used
a lot of the time in law, however,
is to not question it at all,
just exactly the opposite
of how it became such a wonderful
and playful medium of entertainment.
Anyway, thank you very much.
[applause]
>> Roberta Shaffer: Please join me
in thanking Professor
Silbey one more time.
I also want to thank my
colleagues, Rob Stone
and Lea Cavalla [Assumed Spelling],
who really made this event possible
and have planning it
for several months.
There is going to be a videotape
so you can hear it again,
but also tell your friends to go
to The Library of Congress website
and see and hear this
wonderful presentation,
which will also be closed captioned.
And I thank all of
you, the audience,
for attending the event today.
Thank you so much, Professor Silbey.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of The Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.